ابدا
بالتحيه لكل اهلنا في قطاع غزه وعلى
امتداد ارضنا المحتله في
فلسطين التحيه للعائلات الصابره المرابطه
الراسخه في
ارضها العصيه على الاقتلاع
المرتبطه بارض غزه العزه واترحم على
الشهداء شهدائنا الابرار شهداء شعبنا
شهداء مقاومتنا وادعو بالشفاء العاجل
للجرحى والمصابين والمرضى
واتوجه بالتحيه لهم جميعا وهم الذين
يصنعون هذا النصر
والتحيه والسلام والفخر والاعتزاز بابطال
المقاومه بكل كتائب المقاومه لا سما كتائب
القسام وسرايا القدس رجال المقا الذين
يسطرون ملاحم البطوله ملاحم ستدرس فصولها
في التاريخ وستبقى خالده على مسيره
شعبنا حتى يتحقق النصر والتحرير
والعوده وابدا الحديث بالوضع
الانساني اذ خلال
38 يوما على العدوان الصهيوني وحرب
الاباده الجماع بحق شعبنا في قطاع غزه
ارتقى من ابناء شعبنا نحو
22000 من
الشهداء واصيب بجراح اكثر من
56000 اغلبهم من النساء والاطفال اذ
تجاوزت نسبتهم
74% كما ان هناك اكثر من 9000 مفقود تحتر
كام البناء الذي هدم وتحت المساكن التي
دمرها القصف النازي المجرم وتمنع طواقم
الاسعاف والدفاع المدني من الوصول الى
هؤلاء المفقودين في جرائم حرب متعدده
متجدده امام مراى ومسمع العالم لقد ارتكب
هؤلاء النازيون الجدد خلال الساعات ال4 ال
ماضيه اكثر من 20 مجزره مروعه بالسلاح
الامريكي وبالذ خائر
الامريكيه وابيد فيها عائلات
باكملها وكلهم مدنيون
ونازحون وارتكبت هذه المجازر في بيت لاهيه
وجباليا والمغازي والبريج وخانيونس على
امتداد قطاع غزه من شماله الى جنوبه
وارتقى خلالها فقط 300 شهيد و400 جريح وهو
اذ يرتكب هذه الجرائم فانما يتعمد ذلك عن
قصد واراده لا تقتصر هذه الاراده وهذا
القصد على المجرمين من ساسته وقادته
العسكريين بل
تتعداها الى الجنود في الميدان وهذا نموذج
لجندي يعترف بقتل طفله عمرها 12 عاما
ويقول انه يبحث عن رضيع ليقتله هذا هو
[موسيقى]
المشهد
لقد صدق العالم كذبا روجه الاحتلال
الصهيوني في بدايه هذا العدوان يوم السابع
من اكتوبر عندما ادعا دون دليل زيفا
وعدوانا وبهتانا ان اطفالا قد قطعت رؤوسهم
وان نساء قد اغتصبن ورغم اكتشاف العالمي
كذب هذا الزيف وهذا الافتراء لكنه لا
يتوقف مطلق
امام جريمه ترتكب بادله حيه ومباشره
ومثبته يقوم بها قاده هذا الكيان وجنوده
على حد سواء وامع اناا في جرائمه النازيه
فقد سرق الاحتلال الفاشي جثامين ثمانين من
الشهداء من مناطق متفرقه من قطاع غزه من
مناطق متفرقه من قطاع غزه بعد قيامه بنبش
القبور واخراج الجثث والعبث بها وسرقه
اعضاء الشهداء ثم لم يكن من دور للصليب
الاحمر سوى نقل الجثامين وتسليمها دون اي
بيانات بشانها وكان شيئا لم يكن اننا
نطالب الصليب الاحمر بتوضيح كامل كيف
يستلم هذه الجثامين دون اي معلومات عن
هويه هؤ ؤلاء الاشخاص وعن كيفيه استشهادهم
وعما جرى معهم وكانه يبدو شريكا في هذه
الجريمه ان هذه الجريمه البشعه تستدعي
تحركا دوليا
لادانته وتجريمها والعمل على تحقيق عاجل
يفضي الى محاكمه مرتكبيها ومنعهم من
الافلات من
العقاب ان هذا الحديث يقودني لنقطه لا تقل
اهميه عما سبق وهي الموت جوعا في شمال
قطاع غزه واتحدث هنا حقيقه لا مجازا فمع
شح المواد
ووصولها من مواد اغاث او طبيه
فان ما يجري في قطاع غزه في شمال قطاع غزه
يعد بحق كارثه انسانيه اذ يواجه اهلنا
الصامدون هناك خطر الموت جوع عن وهو ما قد
بدا يحصل فقد وصل هذا الامر الى حد الفتك
يوميا بارواح العديد من ابناء شعبنا خصوصا
النساء والاطفال والشيوخ والمرضى والجرحى
علاوه على ذلك فان النقص الحاده في المواد
الغذائيه وفي الدواء بات يؤدي الى تفشي
عدوى في الامراض الجلديه والاجهزه
التنفسيه لدى الفئات الهشه صحيه لا سما
الاطفال واصحاب الامراض المزمنه وعلى هذا
ففي شمال غزه من لم يمت بالقصف مات بالجوع
والعطش او مات بالمرض والنزف من الاصابه
حتى النهايه ان هذا الامر يستدعي تحركا
عاجلا من قاده وشعوب الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه واحرار العالم ومن المنظمات
الامميه والضغط لوصول المواد الغذائيه
والدواء لشمال قطاع غزه فكل قطاع غزه بات
منطقه
منكوبه لكن المجاعه تفتك بالابر ياء في
شماله وكل يوم يجري فيه التاخير يحصد
مزيدا من
الارواح اما في المسار
الميداني فان مقاومتنا الباسله تمضي بكل
قوه واقتدار في اداره هذه المعركه
البطوليه دفاعا عن اهلنا في قطاع غزه
وثارا لدماء الشهداء وتضحيات والام ابناء
شعبنا جميعا وانتصارا للقدس والمسجد
الاقصى المبارك اما ما يتعلق بالاحتلال
النازي فان ثلاثي الحرب والعدوان والارهاب
والشر نتنياهو جانتس جلنت ومنذ ما يقارب
من ثلاثه اشهر يسوق انتقاله من مرحله الى
اخرى موهما نفسه وجمهوره بانه يحقق
انتصارا لا وجود له وهم يراكمون في حقيقه
الامر فشلا تلو الفشل مع كل اعلان عن
مرحله جديده يدخلون اليها حتى ان ثلاثي
الشر بات مرتبكا عاجزا عن اعلانه الدخول
في مرحله جديده لانه يعلم نتائجها جيدا
فقد كتب هذا العدوان نهايتهم السياسيه
والعسكريه وكتب كذلك الصفحه الاولى في
نهايه احلامهم في البقاء على ارض
فلسطين لن يجني نتنياهو واركان حكومته
المجرمه سوى المزيد من الخيبه والخسران
واساءه الوجه وان الانتصار الذي يمنون
انفسهم به والقضاء على حماس الذي يحلمون
به ما هو الا اضغاث احلام وسراب سيتلاشى
امام صمود شعبنا وبساله
مقاومتنا لن يرى قاده الاحتلال الغزاه
المجرمون اسراهم لدى المقاومه احياء الا
بعد توقف شامل لعدوانه على شعبنا في قطاع
غزه وعبر تفاوض بما يتوافق مع مصالح شعبنا
العليا و واعيد لن يرى قاده الاحتلال
الغزاه المجرمون اسراهم لدى المقاومه
احياء الا بعد توقف شامل لعدوان على شعبنا
في قطاع غزه وعبر تفاوض بما يتوافق مع
مصالح شعبنا واذ يتبجح نتنياهو بتحرير
اسراه عبر الضغط العسكري فاننا نتساءل هل
من اسير واحد حرره
نتنياهو دون الرضوخ لشروط المقاومه ونقول
وبشكل واضح لعائلات الاسرى الذين التقاهم
قبل قليل ان نتنياهو يكذب
عليكم بالضغط العسكري سيعود ابنائكم جثثا
هامده في توابيت وربما لن يعودوا ابدا اما
بالاستجابه لشروط المقاومه ففرص عودتهم
احياء الى عائلاتهم
محققه ان العدوان الذي يجري في الضفه
الغربيه والقدس رغم اشتداد العدوان في غزه
يبدو ممنهجا وواضحا اذ يتسع ليشمل عموم
الضفه الغربيه ومدينه القدس والمسجد
الاقصى عبر اغتيالات واعدامات ميدانيه
وحشيه واقتحامات همجيه وتدمير للبنيه
التحتيه واستهداف للحاضنه الشعبيه
للمقاومه وحمايه للمتطرفين الذين يواصلون
اقتحام وتدنيس المسجد الاقصى المبارك لقد
ارتقى خلال حمله العدوان تلك منذ السابع
من اكتوبر
313 شهيدا وجرح اكثر من 3000 من ابناء
شعبنا واعتقل ما يزيد عن 5000 منهم في
ضفتنا ضفه العياش الابيه منذ ان بدا هذا
العدوان ولا يزال هذا العدو يمارس عدوانه
على المقدسات ويمنع ويعيق وصول ابناء
شعبنا الى المسجد الاقصى المبارك ان جرائم
الاحتلال تلك هي استكمال لمخططات هذه
الحكومه النازيه المستمر منذ سنوات في غزه
والضفه
والقدس ولن تفلح رغم ذلك في تحقيق
اهدافها ولن تكسر اراده التحدي والصمود
والنضال لدى شعبنا ول نتجح في فرض امر
واقع في الضفه او في المسجد الاقصى
المبارك مهما كان العدوان قاسيا اننا ندعو
جماهير شعبنا وشبابنا الثائره وكتائب
المقاومه الى تصعيد كل اشكال النضال
والتصدي لجرائم الاحتلال
وللمترجم بكل الوسائل كما ندعو الى مواصله
الرباط وشد الرحال الى المسجد الاقصى
المبارك غدا الجمعه وهنا ندعو منتسبي
الاجهزه الامنيه والامن الوطني الفلسطيني
في الضفه الى كسر القيود وان يوجهوا
بنادقهم نحو جنود الاحتلال وقطعان
المستوطنين وان يلتحقوا باخوان في كتائب
المقاومه في ضفتنا ضفه العياش دفاعا عن
الشعب والارض
والمقدسات فيما يتعلق بالمبادرات
والطروحات السياسيه التي يجري الحديث عنها
نؤكد اولا انفتاح الحركه على اي افكار او
مقترحات لوقف العدوان بشكل كامل ونهائي
على شعبنا في قطاع غزه فشعبنا لا يريد
وقفا
م قتا بل وقفا كاملا للعدوان وهنا نؤكد
ايضا ان اداره الشان الفلسطيني هي قرار
فلسطيني وطني داخلي وهو قرار الشعب
الفلسطيني وحده ولن يقبل شعبنا بقياده
تاتيه على ظهر دبابه صهيونيه او امريكيه
او بحمايه هذه الدبابه وان شعبنا اليوم
يريد قياده وطنيه تحمل مشروع التحرير
وتلتزم المقاومه بكل اشكالها لتحقيق
اهدافها الوطنيه لا سما المقاومه
المسلحه فيما يخص المواقف الدوليه من
العدوان نثمن تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
الروسي السيد سيرجي لافروف التي اكد فيها
اهميه رفع الظلم الذي عانى منه
الفلسطينيون على مدى اجيال حتى يتحقق
الاستقرار في المنطقه وهي تؤكد الحاجه الى
اراده دوليه لرفع الظلم عن شعبنا ووقف
العدوان الصهيوني عليه وتمكينه من اقامه
دولته المستقله وعاصمتها القدس وعوده
اللاجئين الى ارضهم ووطنهم وديارهم ونؤكد
كذلك ان اداره الرئيس بايدن هي التي تقود
هذه الحرب العدوانيه
فعلا بمشاركه هذا الكيان جرائمه ومجازره
بحق الاطفال والنساء والمدنيين في انتهاك
صارخ لكل القوانين والمواثيق
الدوليه وان هذه الاداره مسؤوله مسؤوليه
كامله عن هذه الدماء البريئه التي تسفك من
اطفال ونساء وشيوخ وان تسترت وراء حرص
كاذب ومنافق على حياه
المدنيين ان الهجوم المتواصله من كل قاده
الاحتلال ووزرائه المجرمين على مؤسسات
الامم المتحده في شخص الامين العام
والجمعيه العامه بسبب القرارات والمواقف
الفاضحه لجرائم الاحتلال والمندى بها يؤكد
ان هذا الكيان يعتبر نفسه فوق الجميع وفوق
القانون الدولي وهنا لابد من سؤال على
الجميع ان يقدم اجابه عليه الى متى يبقى
هذا الكيان بعيدا عن المحاسبه المسائله بل
والمحاكمه لقد بات من المطلوب اتخاذ مواقف
اكثر حزما تجاه الحكومه الصهيونيه التي
تعيث في الارض فسادا وارهاب وترى نفسها
فوق القانون
والمحاسبه واود هنا ان اشير الى ان حملات
التضليل والتشويه المتعمده لمواقف الحركه
وتصريحات قادتها وال التي تقوم بها اطراف
معاديه لحركتنا وشعبنا من خلال وسائل
اعلام تدور في الفلك الصهيوني لن تفلح في
تشويه حقيقه مواقفنا ونصا مبادئنا
وثباتنا بل وقوه ثباتنا في المواجهه اننا
ندعو الى تشكيل جبهه عالميه تضم كل الدول
الرافضه للعدوان الصهيوني على قطاع غزه و
عمل للضغط على الاحتلال والاداره
الامريكيه لالتزام الفوري بوقف العدوان
وفتح جمي وح جميع المعابر وادخال كفه
المساعدات البيه
والغث والوقود والغاز الى جميع مناق قطاع
غزه دون استثناء ومنع الاداره الامريه من
الاستمرار في استخدام الفيتو لصالح الكيان
الصهيوني استمرار عدوانه على شعبنا
اخيرا ندعو جماهير امتنا العربيه
والاسلاميه واحرار العالم الى تكثيف
حراكهم وفعالياتهم يوم غد الجمعه ويومي
السبت والاحد القادمين تزامنا مع نهايه
العام ومطلع العام الجديد عام
2024 وتضامنا مع غزه وفلسطين ولتكن الايام
القليله المتبقيه من هذا العام صرخه
عالميه انسانيه موحده للمطالبه بالوقف
الفوري للعدوان الصهيوني وللحرب الاباده
ضد شعبنا الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه وتنديدا
بدعم اداره الرئيس بايدن للاحتلال النازي
بل وشراكتها الكامله في جرائمه المجد
والخلود لشهدائنا الابرار الشفاء العاجل
لجرحانا
ومرضانا والحريه لاسرانا
والعزه والنصر لتمكين شعبنا ومجاهدينا
وانه لجهاد نصر او استشهاد والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته يا شباب